- [Voiceover] This is an African Elephant.
The largest land mammal in the world.
So large that it dwarfed our backdrop.
While conservation efforts
have made significant gains,
the threat of poaching still looms over
the future of this giant species.
Distributed through
the deserts and jungles
of Sub-Saharan Africa, their
large ears radiate heat
to keep cool in the African sun.
They eat a lot.
Everything from roots,
fruits, grasses, and bark.
And up to 600 pounds of it a day.
The tusks are firm teeth
used for digging roots,
stripping bark from trees,
and for fighting and defending themselves.
Unfortunately, these ivory tusks can
fetch quite a price on the black market.
Poaching for the illegal ivory trade
continues to be a devastating problem.
This is the African Elephant.
(soft instrumental music)